[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
あの私は早瀬亮平と言いますでいまご荘櫂に当たりました
青山学院大学の体育会のサッカー部でコーチをしております
で傍らあのその大学のサッカー部のコーチをしつつ自分自身であのまあ辺があって
サッカースクール自分自身であの今現在しています
でまあ
ここ本日のテーマでありますように気持ちには引力がある
ちょっとなんかあの壮大なあのテーマというかものすごくなんかなんですね強烈なあの
エネルギーを言葉だけでも感じるようなテーマですけれどもこの言葉はあの僕の言葉
じゃないですね書いてある通り
あの by gori さんとゴリさんっていうあの人の言葉なんですけども
どこのゴリさんの
大人や話ですよねでこのゴリさん
あの僕が高校時代にあのサッカーしてたんですけどもサンフレッチェ広島
っていうところの下部組織に所属してましてあのユースチームの監督この際ですね
強烈ですよね見えるからこれはまあ決して怒っている時じゃなくて優勝したし優勝して
を言う女子終わったあとにもう
気持ちパッカーしているシーンです
ここ
まあこの見る限りこういった感じなので僕はこの人からこの気持ちが陰力があるという
言葉を
あのチームとして共有してなんですけども僕個人としてものすごく重く受け止めしたん
ですねこの言葉で気持ちには陰力あるこの言葉の意味解釈
僕はこのようにあの
とられていました強烈な思い出
自分がたし達成したいことに対して強烈に努力していく
この言葉あの気持ちに陰力があるということはこういうことだ何か僕自身を捉えてあの
高校時代を過ごしていました
今言いました高校時代どういう風な過ごし方をしてはなれば
さあフレンチ広島ユースっていうところですねあの三津谷亮祐亮生活
全寮制なんですねみんな同じ寮に通ってあの学校に行って
サッカーも同じずーっとみんな一緒
ずーっとみんな一緒で
まあ寮生活の話をしますともちろんこの中にでもあの両性花としたことあるよっていう
人はたくさんいると思うんだけども
ちょっと特殊
何が特殊かっていうと10時半になったら携帯ポー集
重視派になったら経済場所ありえん
多分こっちのとが今一で言えばありえないですよね携帯獣ジャンですよる中所で11時
ショートでそのサイクルで行くと朝6時45基調06:55
てんこ
外に出てんこ寒かろうが関係ないの外で店
いう生活をあの高校時代送っていました
でその中で高校時代は当然量だったので
寮長さんという人が入らですね
寮長さんとその今いいましてゴリさんこの2人からのあの言葉のシャワーというかあの
ものすごく強烈な言葉をたくさん言っていただいて
まあ例えば
両町で行くとあの
ものすごいあの大きな目標達成したいことがあるのであれば一つや二つのことを犠牲に
しないとなれよぞ
そのぐらいの気持ちであの自分の目標とは夢に対して取り組みなさいよと
そういう言葉を頂いたりとかゴリさん
あのサンフレッチェ広島の監督の言葉で行くとあの
こうやってミーティングルームでゴリさんがよるあのミーティングしてくれる
お前ら
あのプロサッカー選手になりたいかと
ジェイア
だけどもあのその中でやれることをすべてやってる人いるか
誰もいない
で何人かプロサッカー選手になっていった人はその時に手を挙げれてたと
お前らはそれじゃあ無理だ
そういった1つ1つの言葉が僕にとっては今の自分にとって自分の今のメンタリティを
形作ってくれた
その寮長さんと氷さんっていう人がいたそういうふうなあの
時間を高校時代過ごしてました
まあ遅れながらですけどこんなとこですねあのものすごく
ど田舎女もおらんければ女はいますけれども
あのまあそういう意味じゃなくてね
そういったところで過ごしました夜はあの自転車でかなぁって坂を下っていくグランド
が龍馬でそこでもう一度こちらって見ればしかの目が光っているようになる
そんなところでここじゃ過ごしてました
で現在
まプロサッカーコーチをさせてもらっているわけですけれども
まあ簡単に
まぁこんな感じで
今現在やらせてもらっているというところですで大学時代なんですけども
あの大学時代
僕にとってはあのものすごく
強烈なあの時間を過ごさせてもらいました
なんでそういう風なあの時間を過ごさせてもらったかというと
怪我
絵がです
僕は高校時代の時からプロサッカー選手を志してあのやってましたけれども
大学1年生の終わりにあの
まあ4期生のですよね当然なだけがですから
骨折第5中足骨足の左足の骨を折ってしまって骨折
4ヶ月のところ8か月かかっ
で1か月復帰したけれども最高雪してしまった
この時に
まあ書いてありますけどサッカーがない自分今までもサッカーしかしてないのに
サッカーがない自分を考えざるを得ない時間ができた
それがどういう風なあの自分に対してどういうふうなこともたらしたかというと
こういうこと思っちゃったんですね
なんでかっていうとサッカーをずーっと自分が一生懸命してて自分の目標に向かって
取り組んでいるときは自分のことしか考えなくていいって言ってしまえば
だけども
そういうふうに何だろうナポケーって空白の時間ができたんですね
そういったときにこういうことを
思っちゃう
が変われぬ
別にこれが悪いわけじゃないですよ当然疲れてるんん
これ
なんで就活してるのに自分が選んで就職活動をしているのになんで文句言ってんの
僕が学生4年目の前まで再骨折したんで行った4年目前までかかっちゃったから
僕の同期の人たちは就職活動をしている当然ながらこういうことを考え
なんで
なんで自分のワクワクすることとか発見してそれを追いかけ続けることができないん
これで多分学生に限らずあの社会人
前入れることだと思う
全員何でなんだろうか
怪我によってこれをものすごく考えでこの中で
自分があの自分自身の経験
そういった悩んだ時の経験として
まあ5つのアイデアっていったら大げさですけどもちょっと共有皆さんと共有したい
なっていうところあります一つ目
まあ学生の方向けというかそういう話になってしまいますが学生時代にあの頃が来たり
すべきこと
っていうところであのやりたいことを
素直な気持ちでやりたいことを追ってほしいやってほしい
僕でいうと自分の経験から言うと
おい動画動画がありますかこれ
どこだかわかりますかん
フィリピンがですね
あの
学生4年目の時に
夏休みですね
フィリピンに行ったですなんでフィリピンに行ったかっていうと
中田英寿みたいなことがしたいなと
ボールを現地で買って何十個も買っていろんな場所に行ってあのサッカーを教えると
まではいかないけども一緒に加えてドール
足今日はちっちゃい子なんての片足靴内で嘉田氏話ですからね
そういったよ場でサッカーとやんけどもは茶お茶してあのそういったところから自分が
自身が学べることも数多くか
こうやってうわぁタードみんな写真撮っ
というふうなことをあのしたりとか
ブラインドサッカーのブラインドサッカー最近あのちょっと
をご存知かと思いますブラインドサッカーの運営委員会をしたりとか
学生コーチお米目にしたりとか
あの
まあある会社のインターンシップを10か月させてもらったりとやれること全部やれる
こと全部
全部やったんですねん
でそういったところから学べるものっていうのはものすご効果あっただからこそ
学生時代にはそういうふうに
やりたいことはできる限りやれる範囲やらって欲しいな
でなんでこういうふうなことを言うかというとあの
まあこれはちょっと大げさかもしれないんですけども
学生時代にやりたいことをやって本当にやるべきことをやりたいことを探す本気で探す
じゃないと何が起きるか僕はまだ23歳なので
あの30歳40歳50歳の方がある何を言っとんやお前はと
まだ全然生きてないじゃないかとだけど僕が思うのは学生時代に本気でそこ
あのトライというか見つけようって努力しないと
就職角度して就職しますよね
こちら日本のあの教育の中であの
マインド3落とし込まれているのっていうのは忍耐強く
我慢強く
やりたいことを覚えとかだけそういうことじゃないそういったところ
少しネガティブなところだからこそ入ってしまえば3年間認定直頑張る
何年後ある程度給料上がる慣れてくる仕事も落ちたら例えばですけどね
あの二十五六で彼女ができる
子供ができちゃった
5自分自身のことを本気で考える時間ができる
もしできたとしてもなかなか行動できないアクションできない時間
時間も取られ取られるというかまぁ言葉をあれですけどね
当然ながらそういうふうなあの誰かのために
あの
頑張るとか誰かを幸せにしたいそれも当然僕も思っているし死体 com
だけれども自分自身
何がしたいかというのはやっぱり大学時代にしっかりとあの考えないといけない
っていうところコレ一つ
二つ目本当にしたいことを探す
したくないことはしないこれちょっと大げさですけども僕で言うと僕の経験から行くと
本当にしたいことを探す
したくないとですね
したいこと将来フットサル場の中で自分のフットサル場でサッカーコーチとして現場列
33位タイ
その横にカフェを併設させたりと
いいですよネカフェ終わってそこ行ってバーもあってとか
夢物語ですよ言ってしまえば夢
いわゆるでカフェを作るんだったら自分もカフェのことを知らないといけないと
経営とは言わないですだからカフェのアルバイトをやろう
やる
しか3日で辞めた
残念ながら田中だけどしたくないことはしない
俺はちょっと説得力ないかもしれないけど僕にとってはそれを止めることによって次の
新しいものが入っていた
例えばその後にスイミングプールスイミングプールをか死ぬ
スイミングのコーチをする機会に巡り合えるでその後にそれもまあ2カ月で辞めた
なんでかっていうと
ある日
おいと
あの事務所みたいないるんですね
どうしたお前その顔と
何ですか
髭だよ姫いえど
ひげ開館後だとで僕自身にとってはヒゲを否定されることが自分自身を否定されること
だと
遊フライの気持ちになってでどうするんやお前どうすんや
止めますとそのまでもうやめたんですけれどもそれやめた後に自分自身でやっぱ作家
作りありたい
要は空っぽですよねやることやるべきこととしてもその状態でに入ってきたんですよ
やりたいコックないことをやらずに空っぽにしたら入ってくるこれは僕の経験からしか
言えない
言えないだけどもそういうもんだって僕は思うんですね
それを一つみなさんとこれこの場合共有したい
3つ目
時間大丈夫ですね
3つ目ですねなりたいものがあるしたいことがある
これ
状況としてはここにいる皆さんも思ってることがあるんじゃないですかね
ただなりたいものがあるけれども例えば社長になりたい
経営者になりたい
だけど今はその政府には入ってないんだけど今何すればいい
何をすべきなのか
その時自分が社長とが経営者になっているときの振る舞いを常にしなくちゃいけない
僕で言うとサッカーコーチとして
自分のあの
フットサルコートを持っては運営型もしなきゃいけない
その時の姿で振る舞って言葉もそういう言葉遣いをして
たとえ困難な状況でもそのときの自分であるかのように行動振る舞わないといけない
これは僕自身だけじゃなくてあの
ここにいる皆さんそしてあの何かこういったものを持っている人にとってはそういう
ふうなあのスタンスであのいてほしいなというふうに思い
います
で四つ目ケーションって何だろうか
僕自身転職をあの
探しするというか探したいってなった時に僕は他のひとまわりの人がそれを示して
くれると思う
自分自身がこれが天職だこれが天職になりうるかもしれないじゃなくて
転職っていうのは例えば僕の経験で行くと高校のさっきの郡山ですね郡さんが僕は
サッカー選手以外数がまったくなかったサッカーにかかわる以上だけども
ゴリさんは進路面談の時にお前は何か後輩のことをあの思いやってくれてるからコーチ
が向いてるんじゃないかとその時はもう全くそんなこと思いながらだけど今現在それを
している
だからこそ転職っていうのは周りの人があの示してくれるものだと思うしそういうふう
なものだという風なところは一つ持ってあのおいてほしいなというふうに思います
最後に5つめ命をかけるほどの仕事
ものすごく壮大なまたしてもものすごくとございな話ですけれども
僕自身命をかけるほどの仕事っていうと
あの
ちょっとを苦しいというか
堅苦しいだけど命をかけるというのは結局時間を使っているのと一緒
この瞬間も実際そうですよね命をかけるというと大げさな時間を使っているんだから
時間を
水焦るほどの仕事を見つけるためにどういう風な状況があるの僕は否定的なものこと
だったり
困難なことだったり
自分にとってネガティブな状況が起きた時にここに結びつくと思う
なぜならば
あの最近僕の友達で就職活動
失敗しちゃったと
失敗しちゃった
その人は当然その現場にいる人だから当然も打ちひしがれてい
だけど僕からしたらネガティブな状況こそ自分自身をよりスカ森できる
自分自身のことねだからこそそういうふうに命をかけるほどの仕事を探すにあたって
ネガティブな状況とが否定的な物事が起きた時にこそ自分自身を深掘りできると思って
ほしい
それは一つ僕の経験からあの言えることなのでぜひともこれは一つ
覚えておいてほしいなというふうに思い
最後
夢
僕自身の夢はさっきも言いましたけども
自分自身
女フットサルコートを持ってカフェを平成させたいとがその近くにクラブハウスあって
まーしーてーは横に幼稚園だったりとか慈童保育所
そういうのを作りたい
目に見える頭で浮かべる会としてはそういう感じ
でその中身って何やっ
僕はサッカーを通じで
多くの人が自分の思い描いた人生を歩んでほしい
と思っていますで
なんでこういうふうなことを思ったかというと
僕自身がケガで苦しんだ
その時にさっきも言ったけどもなんでそんな苦しいのに同じことをやっているんだろう
それはいろんな状況がいろんな軸家族がいたり当然だけども
自分自身のこととして捉えてあの
生きていく上で
そういった
何だろうなあのー
自分自身の
何軒ならねー
こととして捉えてほしいんだねで
僕は子供に対して強烈にあの働きかけない
なんでかっていうと子供子供が今の木教委教育を受けている子どもが大人になっていく
となかなか
自分自身のことをあの本気で捉えられなくなってしまう
俺は思うだから
あの僕はこれをあの掲げて今後やっていきたいと
で最後になりますけども
まあ
こういう風なねあの機会を与えてもらったあの仲間
いるんですけどもその人に本当に感謝して今後自分自身のあの夢に対しての
邁進していきたいなというふうに思います
皆さんに今日のプレゼンテーションが少しでも何かこう
ワクワクさせるようなというかあの何かこう火が付くようなきっかけになればとそう
いうふうなことをあの
ができたできたとしたらものすごく僕自身は嬉しいです
本日はご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]